JANICE KEYSER: Welcome,
thank you so much for coming.
I'm Janice Keyser.
I'm one of the site
directors at one
of the Google
Children's Centers.
And I'm delighted today
to introduce my friend
and colleague Rona Renner, who
has been working with me on
and off for several years.
Rona is the co-founder of
Childhood Matters, which
was a wonderful radio
show in Berkeley
in English and in
Spanish for 10 years.
And she is a consultant, a
writer-- as you can tell--
and she's been an incredible
resource to both parents
and educators in the
Bay Area and beyond,
particularly thinking about both
issues of parenting and also
who are these children and how
does temperament effect who
these children are, how
our relationship works.
And it was so
exciting to me when
she called me and let me
know that she was writing
this book because
I feel like it's
going to be such an incredible
resource to families.
The very cool thing is that
Google is supporting in this.
And so Books Inc is at the
back of the room selling
books for $5.
And people can, and they will
have them in the bookstore
so that you can,
with your badge,
go in and buy them for $5
at any point that you want.
For today's Talk, several
people are VCing in.
And if you have questions and
you're VCing in, you can go
to the link go slash
"Is that Me Yelling?"--
the title of the book--
and put up questions.
We'll start questions in the
last 15 minutes, 20 minutes,
so people in the audience
and people who are VCing in
can submit their questions.
Let's see if there was
anything else I needed to say.
Oh, Rona's probably going to
talk a little bit about this
too.
But I helped her get
connected with Google Helpout.
So she is a consultant available
on Google Helpouts now as well.
So without further
ado, it's your turn.
RONA RENNER: It's
great to be here.
And thank you to Janice Keyser.
She and I have worked
together over the years.
She even substituted for
me as the host of my radio
show a couple of times.
So it's a pleasure
to be here at Google.
And I did get on
Google Helpouts now.
So I'm looking forward to
having some consultations
there as well.
So I'm going to speak to
you today as a professional.
I'm a temperament specialist
and a parent educator,
parenting coach.
I'm also a nurse
for about 47 years.
I started when I was very young.
And I love working with parents.
And I'm talking to you as
that professional today,
and also as a parent.
I have four grown children.
They're all doing wonderful
things in the world.
And even though I
look back and see
some of the real
challenges we had,
I want to just give
all of you hope
if you have young children who
are strong-willed or intense,
giving you a hard
time once in awhile.
They make for great adults.
And so I have four children
and two grandchildren.
So I speak as a parent
and a professional.
And I wrote this book
in part because parents
were coming to my classes
that I was teaching,
and they were saying
a lot, you know,
I don't know what's going
on, but I'm yelling.
I'm yelling at my kids.
I'm getting more frustrated.
And because I yelled
once in a while--
I'm not going to say
how much, but it really
wasn't all that often.
But I didn't like it.
And I thought,
that's a great way
to focus a book that's
really about mindfulness.
It's really about
getting to know yourself
and becoming more
aware of yourself.
And it's also about
discipline, which we all
know means to teach.
And so it's a book
that combines a lot
of my interests,
especially temperament.
And just in case you don't
know what temperament is,
it's a person's natural style.
It's the way you
come into the world.
All children are different.
All of you are different.
Some are active,
some are low energy.
Some of you are sensitive.
Some of you may be shy,
others are extroverts.
So that's what
temperament is about.
And I realize that
if parents looked
through that lens
of temperament,
they could understand their kids
so much better and themselves,
and it could really
reduce power struggles.
So there's a lot of my
book about that as well.
I'm going to read a
little bit from my book.
I'm going to talk with you, and
then I'll take your questions.
This is from the very
beginning, the introduction.
"Some years ago,
my daughter Carina
was downstairs yelling
at her brother Matt
to stop bothering her.
Angrily running to the stairs,
I immediately responded
at the top of my lungs, 'Carina,
stop yelling!' in that moment,
certainly not the
first of such moments,
I suddenly heard myself.
Is that me yelling?
I was appalled.
I was a nurse, a parenting
expert-- I knew better.
That day, I promised
myself that I
would try to stop doing
things that I didn't want
my kids to do,
starting with yelling.
I came to see that my
actions were not always
the best approach
for my children.
But when I paid attention
and made efforts over time,
I learned from my mistakes.
After all, I had
stopped smoking,
and I could stop yelling too.
Parents find themselves
yelling at their kids
for a lot of reasons.
Maybe you were
raised by a yeller
and you can't seem to kick the
habit of letting your feelings
spill out and land on your kids.
Now you want to rid
yourself of some traditions
that you just don't
think are healthy for you
or your family."
I think that's what happens
when we become parents.
We see all of our traditions,
all of our conditioning,
and then we have to
decide, what do we think?
What do we think is best?
Or perhaps you're
under a lot of stress
and have temporarily
lost or misplaced
your compassion,
kindness, and gratitude.
This happens easily
during parenthood
even though you've
discovered deep wells of love
for your children
at the same time.
Since I first became
a parent in 1970,
I've learned that we
all make mistakes,
that there's no such
thing as a perfect parent,
and that parents
love their children.
We have the best of
intentions, but we're all
limited by what
we know how to do.
And so yelling can really be
reduced if you want it to be.
Just thinking about
it will help you.
Someone just saying looking at
the title of the book helped
them yell less, just being
remind that, in fact, it's
a good thing to do
is to yell less.
So I should say something about
what I mean by yelling, right?
If you're being firm with
your child-- stop jumping
on the couch now, it's
time to go out and play,
with that firm, clear
voice, that's not yelling.
That's not what
I'm talking about.
I'm talking about
yelling when you lose it,
when you lose your cool
and the intensity goes up.
Your blood pressure goes up.
You feel your pulse
getting faster,
your face maybe gets hot.
Your fists are clenched.
You know that
feeling a little bit?
And it's good to identify
what that feels like for you.
And then all of a
sudden, you blow.
I've had enough!
Don't you know
it's time to stop?
Why can't you ever behave?
I'm sick of this!
That kind of thing.
It doesn't have to be those
words, but it's that intensity.
And of course, what kids
hear is, I'm sick of you,
not I'm sick of
it, whatever it is.
And so kids do take on
a sense that they've
done something wrong but
also that they're bad.
And one of the things we
want to do a lot in parenting
and teaching young
children is differentiating
between a child
who's misbehaving,
that their behavior is not OK--
pulling your sister's hair is
not OK, but it doesn't
make you bad person.
I think it's really important
in child development
to understand that.
And a lot of research
has been done
about how yelling
impacts children, how
it affects children.
Most professionals
agree that yelling
has an impact on a child's
feelings about themselves,
their world, and the
relationships they
have with their
parents and others.
According to psychologist Myrna
Shure, when parents discipline
by yelling and commanding
their children,
they're more likely that
the children are then
more likely to show physical
or verbal aggression.
These children will
have more difficulty
with positive social
behaviors such as taking
turns and empathizing
with others.
Now I'm going to tell you about
another study that was done.
It came out last year.
And this is with the
University of Pittsburgh.
And they followed 967
middle school students.
And there's a lot to yell about
when you have a middle school
student, I have to say.
It's a hard time for
students and for parents.
Anyone here have a
middle school student?
No?
OK.
Yeah, they're great.
They should just be out
on a farm somewhere.
I think a farm would be a really
good place for middle school
students.
Those whose parents used
harsh verbal discipline
such as yelling, cursing,
and using insults
were more likely to be depressed
or have behavior problems.
The research showed this.
The study found that it
was also not effective
in getting kids to stop
what they were doing.
In the moment, if
you yell, a child
might stop and do
what you say, right?
They've been trained
if you really
yell loud enough to stop.
But it doesn't seem to prevent
them from doing it again.
And I think the key
there is that we're
trying our best as parents
to-- or uncles, some of you
might be uncles if
you don't have kids,
or aunts-- we're trying
to teach problem solving,
not just put like a
damper on the behavior.
And this study was
very interesting.
It said that even
when children are
raised in homes that were
generally warm and loving,
they found the
consequences, these effects,
still on these middle
school students.
So the study is suggesting that
even if you're warm and loving,
the yelling or harsh verbal
discipline will still
have an impact.
And I just want to say
something about that.
It's very important
that parents know
it's never too late to
shift your parenting style,
to shift your discipline.
You shouldn't feel that
just because I did it
for years means my kid is
hopeless, I'm hopeless,
and nothing's going to help.
I believe that what you do, the
love that you give your kids,
the meals you make,
the fun places you go,
the times you sit and
read together, how
you take care of them when
they're sick, all of that
matters.
It really does matter.
And I think what this study is
saying perhaps-- I'm not sure,
but perhaps-- is that kids
remember though that yelling.
It really stands out.
And you could think about
it with the relationship
with your partner or
boyfriend, girlfriend, spouse.
If you've had a fight,
if you've had an argument
and they say something that
really hurts your feelings,
that stays with you.
Same thing with a boss,
coworker-- that stays with you.
And they may do
lots of nice things.
But somehow, those hurtful
words stick around.
And now you can repair that.
And I have a part
in my book about how
to repair when, in fact, you
say things that you really
wish you never would have said.
It's possible to
repair relationships.
But kids remember it.
So the story there
is do your best
to learn how to respond
rather than react.
Most parents are
yellers now and then.
You're not alone and I
think it's really important
to know that you can change.
So how do you do that?
Well, the first thing I
always ask parents to do
is think about why they yell.
Why am I yelling?
And we won't do the
mic here, but I'll
just ask, if can yell very loud,
some of the reasons you yell.
Who here would like to say?
Just call out, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Kids aren't listening.
RONA RENNER: Kids
aren't listening.
That's one of the main reasons.
Why else do you yell if you
yell, your partner yells maybe?
AUDIENCE: Frustration.
RONA RENNER: Frustration,
you're tired.
Anyone here have a
little sleep deprivation
going once in a while?
Yeah.
Your tired, you're frustrated,
kids aren't listening.
Maybe you're really
mad at someone else
and you're taking
it out on your kid.
That happens.
People yell sometimes because
they're dealing with trauma.
Maybe someone died
in the family.
Maybe you're depressed.
You're yelling a
lot of the times
because your
expectations often are
that your child will
do what you say.
Especially-- I notice this
a lot with professionals--
they're used to
getting things done.
High level professionals
get things done.
You ask a co-worker
to do something,
and often they'll do it.
And if you're a
manager, you're used
to being able to tell the people
under you, please do this.
And they'll do it.
But kids don't work that way.
Kids have a mind of their own.
They have little two-year-old
minds and three-year-old mines
and ten-year-old minds.
So I think it's
important to realize
that we have to have
realistic expectations.
A child who doesn't want
to get ready in the morning
to go to school
doesn't know that you
have a meeting at 9:00.
And you know they don't
really care, right?
It's not part of their world.
And so they know that they
like hanging out and playing
with one more LEGO game.
So think about what's
realistic for your child,
and especially the
type of child you have.
What would your child tell you?
If your child could express
how yelling effects her,
what do you think she would say?
At a home visit I made in
a professional capacity,
I asked a seven-year-old
boy, if you had a magic wand
and you could make a
wish to change something
about your father,
what would it be?
He replied without
hesitation, I wish
that he didn't yell
anymore, at me or my mom.
His father's stern face softened
and as he listened to his son.
And he held back tears.
He made a commitment,
then and there,
to do more about
managing his anger
and working on his marriage.
A lot of my book is about
no shaming, no blaming.
When you begin to observe
things about yourself--
and many of you probably
know about mindfulness,
and some of you might practice
meditation or mindfulness--
but the key is that when you
begin to observe yourself,
you have to be kind to yourself.
If you're going to
notice what you do
and then give yourself a
really hard time-- what
a lousy parent, I never
do it right-- then
you're going to stop looking.
So being a good
enough parent means
that you're not
perfect-- there's
no such thing as
a perfect parent--
and that you're
willing, that you
are willing to see what's true.
Not an easy thing.
So in my book, I use the
cognitive behavioral approach.
And that has to do with
noticing your thoughts,
noticing your feelings.
What am I feeling right now?
What am I thinking?
And then be being able to
shift that into something else.
And I'll go into more detail
about that in a minute.
So the key is triggers.
We talked a little bit
about what triggers you.
Your kid's not listening.
Your kid's being maybe fighting.
Anyone here have
more than one child?
Maybe some of you listening?
Yeah.
Does fighting ever
happen in your house,
where the kids are
fighting with each other?
Yeah, it's a real trigger
for a lot of people.
External triggers
are things that
happen-- kids fighting, leaving
their toys around, whining.
That's a big one.
A lot of parents hate
it when kids whine.
Tantrums, those are
external triggers.
But chances are you're not
going to yell unless you also
have escalating thoughts.
So for example, my husband
leaves his underwear
on the floor or the
towel on the floor.
And so the external trigger
is the towel on the floor.
The internal trigger-- and
my husband doesn't do this,
he's fabulous.
This is a hypothetical.
The internal
trigger is, why do I
have to be the maid around here?
Why do I have to clean up?
Why can't he put
his things away?
I don't understand.
So there's an escalation.
I need some water.
Thinking about
towels on the floor
must have gotten me-- so
there's an escalation that
happens in your brain.
And the thoughts, the
negative thoughts,
stimulate more of
that adrenaline,
more of that cortisol.
And that's when you're
more likely to blow.
And cortisol and
adrenaline, you know
a lot about the fight
and flight and freeze.
It's useful in situations
where we really
have to fight or flight.
But in my relationships, I've
learned fighting and flighting
is not the best way to go.
It just really isn't
the best way to go.
So I feel frustrated.
I have these
escalating thoughts.
There's nothing wrong
with my feelings.
They teach me, they
inform me that I've
got to talk to my
husband again about not
leaving his stuff all around.
Anger it's OK.
It's normal.
It's just another emotion.
It's what we do with it.
So now I have these
thoughts, oh, I
can replace them with
something more neutral.
God, he's so good
at so many things.
Maybe I could just
let this one go.
Or I know he was really
in a rush this morning,
or oh gosh, he's just like his
father was, whatever it is,
but something that kind
of brings you down.
And that's the
beginning of being
able to be responsive
rather than reactive.
And it really, really
does work to have
awareness of what
you're feeling.
And it took me years
to figure this out.
Because we're like this--
we're going really fast, right?
So to become aware of what
you're feeling, what you're
thinking, and see if you
can shift it a little bit.
And I'll talk more about that.
And in the book, there are
a lot of common triggers
that people can
identify with and begin
their process of
understanding their own.
And in the book "Full
Catastrophe Living"
by Jon Kabat-Zinn, he
defines mindfulness
as moment to moment
awareness cultivated
by purposefully paying attention
to things we ordinarily
never give a
moment's thought to.
So breathing is an
example of something
that we normally don't
pay attention to.
And you can be
mindful at any time.
You could be driving
in the car and noticing
your hands clenched
on the steering wheel.
Next time you're
driving in traffic,
take a couple of breaths.
Become aware of how you're
feeling, what you're thinking.
See if you can relax your body.
It's a way to be
in the presence.
So much of our life is spent
in the past or in the future.
Your work kind of pulls
you to the future.
You're often evaluating
what's going on in the past.
So we actually have to make
a very conscious effort
to be in the present moment.
What do your children see?
Whether or not you're
aware of yourself,
your children are
constantly observing you.
They're watching
you go like this
are cursing when
you get cut off.
Jon, a psychologist
and a great dad,
told me the story of how
his nine-year-old daughter
Carrie gave him feedback
about the morning monster.
One day at breakfast, Carrie
walked into the kitchen
making a mean face and jumping
around with a wide stance,
making ape-like
a monster sounds.
Jon laughed and asked
her what she was doing,
and what kind of animal was she.
She replied, I'm being
the daddy monster.
This is what you look
like in the morning.
Chagrined, Jon asked her why
she thought he looked like this.
And she simply
said, because you're
angry all the time
in the morning.
Jon thanked her for letting
him know-- after all,
he was a psychologist.
And he sheepishly walked
off and looked in the mirror
to see if the monster
was still there.
And it was.
Jon realized he
was rushing around
in the morning with a
million things on his mind.
And although he
wasn't always angry,
he was preoccupied
and frequently
irritated by how long
things were taking
and how much there was to do.
His daughter's feedback
increased his desire
to observe himself and
be more present with what
was going on in the moment
rather than just worrying
about the future.
Your children are perceptive and
sensitive, and you can be too.
Now it's your turn
to see yourself.
And when you get a glimpse
of your angry monster,
see if you can become friends
and get to know each other.
And again, I know--
I have grandchildren,
and I know how busy life can be.
Everyone's sitting here and
everyone listening remotely,
you probably work long hours.
And if you have
kids, you're busy.
And it feels like you can't
be present in the moment.
But you can be, because in fact,
sometimes it takes less time.
Just that extra hug
or that extra, sure,
I'll read to you, but
just for five minutes,
can save you time because a
meltdown might happen otherwise
that might take a lot longer.
And I tell parents a lot, I
do temperament consultations
with parents, and I
tell them that it's
really important to think about.
Even though you're tired,
getting up 10 minutes earlier
to have your coffee, take your
shower before your kids are up,
that alone might be able
to help you in the morning
feel less of that
monster feeling.
And for everyone it's different.
And I think the real focus in my
book is that you're the expert.
You're the expert on your
child, on yourself, not me.
And part of being the expert
is to become more aware
of yourself.
And the temperament
part in my book--
there's a whole chapter
on temperament--
helps you identify your
traits and your child's traits
and see where there's a good fit
and maybe not such a great fit.
I had one child who's fabulous.
He's doing great
things in the world.
And I adore him, and he
was an intense person.
And so am I. And so we both get
very passionate about things.
But when he was a young child,
he and I would escalate.
He'd do something,
I'd do something.
And it gets up there.
And I really had to
learn, I had to learn
how to manage my own intensity.
I remember one time
he did something--
I think I won't say what it is,
because he'll probably watch
this-- so he did something
that made me really mad.
And I thought, I just can't
go there and scream at him.
I've got to calm down.
And I said, you go to your
room until I cool off.
And I realized that's
what I needed to do.
I needed to cool off
before I responded to him.
And then I was able to
give him the discipline
that I thought was appropriate.
One time he was also
yelling about something.
So I went to his back door, and
I started yelling, ignore him,
folks out there listening.
He's just having a tantrum.
And he said, mom, you're
being so embarrassing.
Stop.
I said, I'm not going
to call CPS, whatever.
And I started laughing
and he started laughing.
And I said, OK, if
you stop, I'll stop.
You've got to use sense
of humor with kids
too, especially
when they're older.
So the temperament
chapter is really
important in understanding your
style and your child's style.
There's a yelling
tracker in my book.
And the yelling tracker
is the key tool.
You know like when you want
to figure out your finances,
you have a tracker to
track your spending.
If you're going to Weight
Watchers to lose weight,
they give you a
tracker so that you
could know, what
is it I'm doing?
And so my yelling
tracker basically
tells you for
maybe a week or two
when you've yelled, go
back and say, when was it?
What time of day?
Maybe it's always at 4 o'clock.
If you're home at 4:00,
you might melt down.
Or it's always in the morning.
Notice what you did and
what your child did.
And then notice how you
felt about what happened.
And think about, what could
I have done differently?
So the tracker is one
of those key pieces
in the book that really helps.
The ABCDEs of not yelling, let
me just very briefly tell you
what that is, and again
go into much more detail.
So A is, ask yourself what
I'm thinking and feeling,
just like I mentioned.
B, breathe.
When in doubt, take a
couple of belly breaths.
It's amazing.
I think the research shows that
it takes about six seconds--
there's an organization
called sixseconds.org--
and I learned from them that
it takes about six seconds
to start lowering your
cortisol and coming back
to your grounding.
So if there's no emergency,
if your child's not
about to run into the street--
because then you want to yell,
right?
If they're going to
run into the street,
yell as loud as you can.
But if there's no
emergency, you don't
have to discipline right then.
Take time to breathe.
Ask yourself, what am I feeling?
What am I thinking?
C is calm yourself.
So through your breath
you'll calm down.
You might need to get
a glass of water--
if it's the evening,
maybe a glass of wine.
Your coffee, spray
some rosemary spray,
whatever helps you feel good.
Go to the bathroom,
I don't know.
So calm yourself is C.
And then D is,
decide what's needed.
OK, I'm calm now.
Because when you're
angry and you're
in your primitive
brain-- Dan Siegel
talks a lot about the brain.
He's a psychiatrist in LA.
And he talks about
the higher level
brain and then the
primitive brain.
And when you're angry,
you wind up right
in that primitive brain.
And you know what?
You're not thinking
at your best.
My husband used
to say, you know,
it feels kind of
good being angry.
You get all this
energy, you know?
It's not so bad.
But in fact, you're not
making the best decisions
unless you have to
fight or flight.
So decide.
Calm down and decide
what's needed.
Your kids are fighting.
Maybe all that's needed
is you need to say, OK
guys, separation, five minutes.
Go play by yourselves.
Or one of you come
make dinner with me,
the other one go set the table.
Or are you wait a minute to
see if they can work it out.
Every family's
different in terms
of what you think is
the right thing to do.
Decide, does my
child need a hug,
or do they need to
limit being set?
But when you're clear, you'll
be able to decide that better.
And then the last part
is E, ABCDE, empathize.
Oh, right.
She just came back from
her dad's house last night.
It's always rough the
day she comes back
and we have to make
that transition
to mom's house and dad's house.
Right.
There's always some acting out.
I need to spend a little
more time with her today.
Or empathize with a child who
just isn't feeling so good,
or with your child on
what ever level you can.
Take a minute to see
what are they feeling.
And also have some
compassion for yourself.
Boy, I'm in a grouchy mood.
I didn't get much
sleep last night.
No wonder I'm acting this way.
So the a ABCDE is a
quick way to help you.
It's like one woman
who read my book said.
She said, Rona, I feel like
I have you on my shoulder
going ABCDE, ABCDE, and I
have to just go, all right.
Ask myself, breathe, calm
down, decide, empathize.
So it's a tool for you.
In the book, I also have
the four C's of discipline.
Now, discipline is
such a huge subject.
And I address it in the book
with an umbrella of the four
C's.
And I don't give every possible
discipline tip you could want,
because again, you have
to know your child.
You have to know your style.
And hopefully if you have
a partner or a spouse,
the two of you are
talking about how
actually to agree
on the discipline.
That takes a lot
of effort, yeah?
Yeah.
So the four C's
are communication.
You're not going to
say to a teenager,
now, don't come home late.
You're going to say,
be home by 12:00.
You have to be specific
in your communication.
Now come on Jane, be good.
What does that mean?
You have to be specific
in your communication.
Choices are another C.
Too many choices are not
so good for kids.
But once in awhile, they
really need some sense
that they have a little
bit of say in their life.
So my grandson, I
was with him and he
needed to take a
shower the other day.
And I said, Maceo,
you need a shower.
Do you want to take it
now or in 15 minutes?
And he said, I don't want
to take a shower now.
I said OK, I'll set my timer.
Timers are a great
tool for parents,
and I have a whole section
on timers in my books.
I set the timer on my
phone for 15 minutes.
He heard it go off, and he
happily went into the bathroom.
Because somehow it's like
neutral, it's not like someone
bossing me around.
It's just the timer.
But that choice helped him
prepare himself for something
that he really
didn't want to do.
Some children really need
to have their choice of what
to wear in the morning, even
though it's not matching.
It doesn't match,
but maybe I could
let them go up to the wonderful
child care that Janice does.
The third C is consequences.
I have a whole section
on family meetings.
Because as a family, you
need to spend time thinking
about what the rules are.
Here at work, if you're here
on your job, you get a sense--
and I'm sure it's
always changing--
but a sense of what
they are the rules.
What am I allowed to do,
what am I not allowed to do?
And maybe there's
a lot of leeway.
But the family rules
are really important.
And then you can talk
about the consequences.
And if you have some rules
on the refrigerator even,
it's easier to remember
what you said the rule was.
Because I used to have
trouble remembering,
what did I say here?
So you want to think
about the consequences.
And I don't believe in
harsh, punitive discipline.
I've just worked
with enough parents.
I used to teach classes in
Richmond, California in Oakland
and all over the Bay Area.
And it's become so clear to me
that harsh punishment doesn't
really teach kids to be the
adult you want them to be,
because they've got to
learn to solve problems.
It really is about play
and problem solving.
But there are times
they need consequences.
And the book talks
a lot about that.
I think a consequence might
be that your child forgets
her lunch box for a
few times in a row,
and you don't rescue
her and rush off
to bring her her
lunch the next time.
And then she remembers, I
need to get my lunch box.
There's a lot of ways to
think about consequences.
The last one of the
four C's is connection.
Even if you work
full time, there
are ways to make sure you
connect with your kids.
And if you have
more than one child,
I strongly recommend you have
special time with each child.
And parents will
say, well, but it's
the family time on the weekend.
We all need to be together.
But the truth is that
kids-- I believe-- they also
need time one-on-one
with the parent.
Because when you're
one-on-one with a child,
you're less frustrated.
And you get to rediscover
what's wonderful about them.
I'm going to be sure and
save time for questions.
So let me just read
a little bit more.
Use humor, creativity.
Pick your battles.
You've all heard this.
But really think about
what's important.
What do I want to have
a consequence for?
And there are things
maybe I could just let go.
In my book there's a section
on special circumstances.
If you're divorced, single
parent, foster parent,
if you have a child with a
disability or a disorder,
there are children with
Attention Deficit Disorder.
I used to work a lot with
parents whose children were
diagnosed with
that, big subject.
We won't get into it here.
But sometimes a
child who's impulsive
will really trigger you more.
And you could have a
child with a disability
and you're working so hard
to be an advocate for them.
And you're fuel tank goes low.
So there's a lot
on that as well.
I think I'll end this
part because we'll
get to your questions with
a thought to consider.
If only we could
protect our children
and ourselves from all suffering
and pain, that'd be so nice.
We can't, but we can do our best
to manage stressful situations
that throw us off balance.
Yelling doesn't make
anything better.
It only takes you further away.
We all make mistakes
as parents and miss
clues pointing to the
way towards healing.
When your kids are
grown, you'll look back
and realize the things you
could have done differently.
If only you had been more aware,
knowledgeable, courageous or
kind.
Forgive yourself for
mistakes you've made
and do what you can now to
make a difficult situation
a little bit easier.
Spend a few minutes each day
thinking about the things
you're grateful for.
This will help you restore
your balance during hard times.
And the book ends
with the words,
"World peace begins at home."
Because I've been thinking
a lot about how frustrated
I feel sometimes,
that I don't know
what I can do to make this
a more peaceful world.
I'm sure many of you have
that feeling too when
you listen to the news
or Google something.
And I realized that if we all
do what we can in our homes,
it actually matters.
When we do our best to treat our
children, others, and ourselves
with kindness and respect,
even with our imperfections,
there's a ripple effect.
A shift takes
place in ourselves,
in our children, and the people
we interact with every day.
When we heal our wounds
with courage and honesty,
we can use our energy
for our benefit
and the benefit of others.
One person like you or me
can have a significant impact
on the violence,
greed, suffering
and lack of compassion
around us all.
If more parents model respectful
communication and empathy--
because your children are
learning from you-- then
the next generation will
have a better chance
to create a more peaceful world.
Consider these
questions every day.
What will I discover today
that brings meaning to my life?
What will I learn
from my children,
and what will they
learn from me?
And how can I offer love,
comfort, or peace to someone?
And I end with those
words because I even
see it with my adult children,
my oldest son just turned 44.
And I realize it's an
ongoing, lifelong process
of learning how to be
the person you want to be
and raising a child
to be the adult you'd
like to see the world
have in the world.
And that's where I feel
so grateful that I've
learned a lot.
And this book, I think,
shares both the mistakes
I've made-- some
of, them just a few.
There are a lot more,
just a few in the book.
But also the things that
I've learned to change.
So I'm going to stop talking
right there for a minute
so I can take your questions.
AUDIENCE: My question is
about how much of what
you've been talking about
and the topic of your book
would you say applies equally
well to grown up children,
if you would, adults?
RONA RENNER: Yes, it's a good
question, how much of this
applies to adult
relationships, right?
And I have these
two dear friends.
And they bought
the book because it
was their friend who wrote
it, but they don't have kids.
And they've been
reading it together.
And they say that it's
really helped them
in their arguments
and their fights.
Because the truth
is, I'm talking
about how do you respond
rather than react?
And when a partner
does something suddenly
and you're angry or
frustrated, there you are.
You have a lot of
choice right then.
You either go right with it
and you get into that argument,
or what I learned to
do with my husband--
I have a great
husband, and we've
worked hard on this--
is to say, wow.
I'm feeling kind of
frustrated here or mad.
I need to cool off first.
And when I do that,
it's really important
to say, and let's
talk in five minutes.
Because if you just leave--
unless it's dangerous,
of course you leave-- you raise
up a lot of abandonment issues
as well.
But in the workplace
too, someone-- and I
was talking with
someone earlier,
and he was asking about, can
this be used in the workplace?
Absolutely.
When I work with parents,
I often say to them,
think of a boss you've had
who was a really good boss.
What were some of
those qualities?
I had a great boss when
I worked at Kaiser.
He had a sense of humor.
He was encouraging.
He gave me a lot of
autonomy, but gave
me feedback if things
didn't go well.
And I thought of
all those qualities.
And those were qualities
that I wanted as a parent,
because children look
to you as their boss.
So I think it's
very transferable
in your relationships with
coworkers and partners.
Also the temperament
part, some of the issues
that couples have are not
because one person is right
and one person is wrong.
It's really about their
difference in temperament.
You might have a very
low energy level,
so you want to stay
home and watch baseball
or just kind of read a book.
And your partner might
have a lot of energy,
and they want to go,
go, go and do, do, do.
And it's not like one of
you is wrong or right,
but it's that temperamental fit.
So I think even though
the focus of the book
is on yelling and yelling
for parents and children,
what I write about is so
applicable, because that ABCDE
can work with anyone.
And is that answering
your question?
Yeah.
And I really
appreciate those of you
who came today who
aren't parents.
Because you were
kids at one point,
and you know what it's like
being raised by parents.
So you may someday be a parent
or an uncle or an auntie.
And knowing this information
can be very valuable.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: My question, you
touched on something earlier
and it made me laugh
just for the second,
because that's what we're going
through with my child now,
is that constant whining.
RONA RENNER: Whining.
AUDIENCE: And I'm curious
if your book addresses
ways to combat that,
because it seems
like sometimes the only way
we can get her attention
to stop whining is if we raise
our voice to just stop them.
Otherwise, it's a constant loop
of just high-pitched whining
or screaming or crying, or
whatever the moment warrants.
RONA RENNER: Yes.
And how old is she?
AUDIENCE: She's three.
RONA RENNER:
Three-year-old who whines.
The three-year-old
is really trying
to figure out their power.
How much power they have, and
can they get what they want.
And I think with whining,
it's similar to a lot
of other things.
If what you're doing isn't
working in parenting,
stop doing what you're
doing and think,
how else can I approach this?
I'm a smart person here.
What can I do differently?
Well, for some people,
they just won't respond.
They just zip it when
the kid is whining.
And they can tell them, look.
When you speak to me like
that, I'm not going to respond.
I need you to take
it over again.
You've probably
tried that, right?
And will she take it over again?
Right, and I'll
repeat what she said.
She just keeps whining.
It might stop for a second.
I've done it where, with the
little older children I've had,
someone used a tape recorder
and let them listen and ,
take your phone out,
and let them listen.
This is what
whining sounds like.
Because you may
not understand what
I'm talking about, especially
because she's probably intense.
And so she has that kind
of passion and intensity.
This is what it sounds like.
Now, I'd like you to practice.
Let's practice.
And when she's
not in a bad mood,
I want you to
practice how to ask
me the same thing
without whining.
And then of course, you give
the positive feedback to that.
But parents will
often react because
of their own frustration.
It's as though the whining
is getting under their skin.
And so you have to work
on that ABCDE breathing.
And if it's in public, you need
to take her into the bathroom
or take her-- it's
just like a tantrum.
AUDIENCE: It's more
like when I'm driving.
RONA RENNER: When
you're driving.
Oh, don't they know how to get
to you when you're driving?
And I found that if I wasn't on
the freeway, I would pull over.
And I know you're often in
a rush to get somewhere,
but I'd pull over
and say, I can't
drive when you whine
because it's dangerous.
I'm afraid I'll get
into an accident
because you're whining
and really bothering me.
Or wear a headset
and just ignore it.
That's the other thing to try.
So the idea here is, again.
Without knowing, I'd want
to know her temperament
and help you that way.
Just try different things.
But don't let her strong
reaction then make you react.
And that's with the yelling is.
You just want it to stop.
And what you're teaching
her, in a way, when you're
yelling is saying, if we
have strong reactions,
we get what we want.
And whining will pass.
It will definitely pass.
But it's a great
question, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you so much for coming.
I just wanted to share that
my daughter, she's three,
and she is a
leader, as they say.
She loves being very
active and leading kids.
And she learned that
if she yells at school,
the kids listen and
it's very effective.
So we've been working with
her trying not to yell.
She doesn't do it at home.
It doesn't work on us.
But she does it a school.
And what I wanted to highlight
is within the framework
that you're describing is
that the teachers at school
came up with this
brilliant idea.
They made a little book--
it's like five pages, pictures
like a little character picture.
And it says, you can
take a breath and.
You can talk to a teacher.
You can move away.
You can read a book.
And it basically gives
you five choices.
So when they catch
her in the moment when
she's about to start yelling,
they give her this little book
and say, choose.
What would you like to do?
RONA RENNER: Fabulous.
AUDIENCE: And so she does,
and then she doesn't yell.
But the beauty is that
you need to catch her
before she yells, because
once she starts yelling,
she's already in
that stage, and she--
RONA RENNER: Right, and the
teacher in this situation
is saying, yelling is
an automatic habit.
And just like for
some of you parents,
yelling is an automatic habit.
And so there are other choices.
And if you can catch it
before your adrenaline kicks
in, same thing with her, but
I love that the teacher has
really developed a book saying
here are some other choices,
it's brilliant.
AUDIENCE: I thought
it was so beautiful.
I took pictures and
I thought, I wish
I had it with me too
sometimes, like if there's
a situation when you get
upset, whip out the book.
RONA RENNER: Well, if you
ever want to send it to me,
I'll post it on my website.
Oh by the way,
nurserona.com is my website.
I should say that.
And I'm also on Google Helpouts.
OK, let's see-- and
NurseRonaRN Facebook.
OK, what specific
strategies can you
offer to deal with young
siblings hitting each other?
My wife and I try
so many things.
We want them to work
things out on their own
without maiming each other.
Good goal, right?
No maiming.
Hitting is coming up a
lot for me in my practice.
A lot of parents
have been calling me
because the kids are hitting.
And I think it's the
kind of thing you really
have to have a serious
family meeting about
and really set that rule--
no hitting in our house.
And a lot of parents,
80% of parents
still use corporal
punishment I'm told.
But a lot of parents
use yelling instead of
hitting, because hitting
was seen to not be so good.
But if you can say no
hitting in our household,
because you don't use that
yourself, it's a good way
to have a meeting
and say, hitting
is not allowed in this house.
And here's why.
I don't want to hit you.
I don't want you
to hit each other.
Those kids, the person who
sent this, thank you very much.
They also need one-on-one
time with each parent
so they're getting
some special attention,
because that reduces
sibling rivalry.
And then you might
have to have it
connected to some
privilege they have.
And I do say that
once in a while,
you need to do that
to break a habit.
And it might be that they love
their TV time after dinner.
And it may be that here's
this very simple chart,
you didn't hit your brother.
There was no maiming today.
You each get your TV time.
And if hitting happens, you
won't, because in our house
there's privilege
and responsibility.
Kids think that the TV
or the iPhone or the pad
is attached to them.
They think it's another
organ sometimes,
especially with older kids.
And we have to remember
that those are privileges.
So sometimes you need
a little leverage.
But I think the first step is to
really have that family meeting
and say, this is
important to us.
We really don't want anyone
in our house to get hit.
I can take another question.
AUDIENCE: Can you suggest any
simple conversational tactics
for suggesting your book to
someone who could probably
use it without seeming
to obviously insult
their capabilities as a parent?
Maybe this person is
even married to you,
or maybe it's a
relative or a stranger.
RONA RENNER: Right,
just like me.
I love it, I love it.
How do you suggest this book?
And I've had a lot of
people ask me that.
And in your case, you
just bring it home
and say, God, I heard this
really good talk at Google
today.
And I just thought-- and
then just leave it there.
But don't say, here honey.
This is for you.
Because she's not going to
like it, or he or whoever
it is, not going
to like it so much.
So you could say,
I got this book.
I thought that I
could learn a lot.
And if you're
interested, we might even
want to look at the
temperament piece together.
There's a whole chapter
on different temperaments.
So that's sort of a safe
neutral place to go.
I've had people ask me
that who are grandparents
and they want to give the
book to their children who
are yelling a lot and.
I think you have to be really
tactful, because no one wants
to be told they're a bad parent.
We feel insecure as parents.
But if you are living with
someone who's yelling a lot,
you can have that honest
conversation, say you know?
I know we have different styles.
You're Italian, I'm not,
whatever you want to say.
And I know we have
different styles.
But I thought maybe we
could read this together,
because the studies are
showing that a lot of yelling
is detrimental to kids.
And I know I'm not perfect
and I do things wrong.
And maybe, maybe you would
yell less if I pitched in more.
Because that's the other thing
I talk about in the book,
that sometimes you're
yelling because you
want your partner to hear that
they need help-- that you need
help, not that they need help.
So I'm busy and I'm
yelling at my kids.
But what I really want is my
partner to come in and help.
So it could open up
a great conversation.
I think it's 12:59.
We need to stop.
And I'll stick around if
anyone has more questions.
And I'd be happy
to sign your books.
And I just want to
thank you so much,
and thank Janice Keyser
for being my host.
[APPLAUSE]